EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS, BUT
AS CNN'S NICK WATT REPORTS THIS
IS BECOMING A RATHER CONTENTIOUS
DEBATE.
>> IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY MORE
THAN 60,000 PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS
ON THE AVERAGE NIGHT AND MORE
THAN 20,000 HOTEL ROOMS LIE
EMPTY ON THE AVERAGE NIGHT.
SEE WHERE THIS MIGHT BE GOING?
>> IT'S JUST INSANE.
IT ISN'T GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
>> WE THINK THIS IS ONE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
BY NO MEANS DO WE THINK THIS
SOLVES THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS,
BUT DO HOTELS HAVE A ROLE TO
LAY?
THINK, THEY DO.
>> SO THE UNION HE LEADS WHICH
REPS HOTEL WORKERS GATHERED
ENOUGH SIGNATURES AND ANGELINOS
WILL VOTE ON A BILL THAT WOULD
FORCE EVERY HOTEL IN TOWN TO
REPORT VACANCIES AT 2:00 P.M.
EVERY DAY AND THEN WELCOME
HOMELESS PEOPLE INTO THOSE
VACANT ROOMS.
>> HONESTLY, WOULD YOU CHECK
INTO A HOTEL KNOWING THAT THE
CHANCE OF YOUR NEIGHBOR TO THE
LEFT OR RIGHT IS A HOMELESS
INDIVIDUAL?
>> MANAJ PATEL VOLUNTARILY RENTS
HOTEL ROOMS TO THOSE VETTED BY A
LOCAL CHURCH, BUT HE'S AGAINST
THIS BILL THAT WOULD MAKE THAT
MANDATORY.
>> WE ARE BARELY SURVIVING,
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, WE HAVE TO THINK OF
THE SAFETY OF OUR STAFF, AND
NUMBER THREE, WE ARE NOT
PROFESSIONALLY OR IN ANY OTHER
WAYS EQUIPPED WITH ANY OF THE
SUPPORTING MECHANISM THAT THE
HOMELESS GUEST WOULD REQUIRE.
>> WHAT SERVICES WOULD BE
PROVIDED REMAINS UNCLEAR.
ALSO UNCLEAR THE FUNDING AND
HOTELS WOULD BE PAID FAIR MARKET
RATE.
>> IT'S UP TO THE CITY.
THEY DID IT DURING PRIVATE ROOM
KEY.
PANDEMIC-ERA PROGRAM NOW WINDING
DOWN THAT INSPIRED THIS BILL BY
PLACING MORE THAN 10,000 PEOPLE
IN HOTELS THAT VOLUNTEERED,
AMONG THEM.
>> IT'S A BLESSING.
IT'S A GREAT ROOM.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT UP TO PAR,
BUT WHAT TECHNOLOGY DO YOU HAVE
IN A TENT?
>> THIS BILL WOULD FORCE
DEVELOPERS TO REPLACE HOUSING
DEMOLISHED TO MAKE WAY FOR NEW
HOTELS AND HOTEL PERMITS WOULD
BE INTRODUCED AS WELL AS MAKING
EVERY HOTEL FROM A SUPER 8 TO
THE BILTMORE ACCEPT HOMELESS
PEOPLE AS GUESTS.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA.
>> WHY NOT?
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH AND
SOME PEOPLE DO SOME DAMAGE TO
THESE POOR BUILDINGS, MAN.
>> THIS WANTED IN PATEL'S HOTEL.
>> SHE MARKED ALL WALLS,
CURTAINS SHE BURNED.
THANK GOD THERE WAS NO FIRE AND
EVEN MARKED THE CEILING.
>> OPPONENTS OF HOUSING THE
HOMELESS AND HOTELS FEAR THIS,
AND FEAR TOURISTS COULD BE PUT
OFF FROM EVEN COMING FROM L.A.
>> I WOULDN'T WANT MY KIDS
AROUND PEOPLE THAT I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO BE IN AN
ELEVATOR WITH SOMEONE CLEARLY
HAVING A MENTAL BREAK.
>> THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN
INTERMINGLE HOMELESS FOLKS WITH
PAYING, NORMAL GUESTS JUST
DOESN'T WORK OUT.
>> WE TONIGHT WANT TO HEAD
BACKWARDS INTO THE SEGREGATED
SOUTH, BUT THAT'S KIND OF
LANGUAGE THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND THERE'S A CERTAIN
CLASS OF PEOPLE, LESS THAN
HUMANS AND ANIMALS THEY ALMOST
DESCRIBE THEM, THEY DON'T SEEM
TO UNDERSTAND THE UNHOUSED AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SENIORS,
STUDENTS, WORKING PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHO THE VOUCHER PROGRAM
WOULD BENEFIT THE MOST.
>> SO ABOUT 18 MONTHS UNTIL THIS
IS ACTUALLY ON A BALLOT AND
EXPECT PLENTY MUDSLINGING
BETWEEN NOW AND THEN.
SOME OPPONENTS HAVE TOLD US THAT
THEY THINK THE UNION IS PUSHING
THIS BILL JUST AS A NEGOTIATING
TACTIC FOR LEVERAGE.
THE UNION THEMSELVES TELL US
THAT IS FALSE, BUT THE UNION
SAYS THEY WANT TO HOLD THE